jessica is with us in Fargo hi Jessica
how are you hi Dave doing good thank you
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up well I have a little bit
of an issue with student loans namely
I'm up to my neck in stupid I took out
way too much when I first started going
to school didn't really realize what I
was getting into and most of them are
private student loans so my private
student loans minimum payment is five
hundred and twenty-five dollars a month
and that is about well and maybe almost
a quarter actually a little over a
quarter what I make in a month
what do you make a year twenty eight
okay what do you do for a living
I work in sales and what is the degree
in well it wasn't intended to go towards
law school but ended up being philosophy
sociology and art and the intention is
to go back to grad school once I had
this paid down and what's the balance on
these student loans for that one it's 40
is that the whole that one I'm a student
I also have my public student loans as
well and that's another thirty okay yeah
all right so 70,000 on $28,000 income so
what's your upside on sales are you
going to be making more yes it looks
like this is the the job has a base pay
that's actually pretty decent the
problem is I'm only getting thirty hours
a week so I picked up a second job and I
am throwing pretty much the entirety of
that at my loan good but it build is not
quite not quite getting there and I'm
not really sure what to do well it's an
income to outgo ratio I mean it's not
it's not really a it's a hard formula
but it's not tough to understand I mean
you're not making a ton and you owe a
ton so the size of your shovel versus
the shot size a hole you're in is the
problem and you're sure you did the
right thing to go get the extra job
and then hopefully your sales job can
continue to go up and maybe we see the
income go up and no there's not there's
not graduate school in your future for a
while right not till you get this mess
cleaned up and then save up the money to
pay for it and then study something that
you can actually use when you come out
get a degree in something that's
actually applicable in the marketplace
if you're gonna do grad school don't
just go to grad school cuz it's cool cuz
it's not that cool really so um
especially with the mess you got on your
hands so good luck with it is all about
getting your income up and continuing to
attack there's not a magic formula I
wish I had a better answer for you but
that's the real answer this is the Dave
Ramsey show
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below
you